every culture is a unique answer to a
fundamental question what does it mean
to be human and alive because the
greatest curse in the history of
humanity a curse that goes back to the
dawn of awareness is cultural myopia the
idea that my world is a real world and
everybody else has a failed attempt at
being me my point is a cultural myopia
and not just a curse of humanity but
it's some one horrific trade of humanity
that in a multicultural in our elastic
interconnected world we can no longer
dodged as if literally all of the glory
of the rain forests and and and the
natural wealth the natural capital of
the forest was just so to be put into a
grinder and ground out to produce money
you know let me ask you a question
what's the formula photosynthesis carbon
dioxide and water sparked by photons of
light creates carbohydrate and releases
oxygen but you could easily graduate not
just from this undergraduate university
but from law school from business school
without knowing the formula of life yeah
how can we possibly get people to
understand the profundity of biological
relationships and profundity of
ecological connections the the
interdependence of life itself if they
are utterly scientifically illiterate we
accept that someone can be fully
educated who has not the slightest idea
of anything to do with biology think
about that that's really what the whole
rap of development is I mean the whole
development paradigm is is is
questionable I mean genocide the
physical extermination of the people is
universally condemned ethnocide the
destruction of a people's way of life is
not only not
it's embraced in many quarters of
appropriate development policy no
pastoral nomads or or or or hunters and
gatherers don't fit the image of the
nation-state and therefore they have to
be eliminated
so I'm just think of it I mean half the
language of the world that were spoken
the day you were born are not being
taught to children which means they're
on the road extinction to lose half the
languages and generation is to literally
lose half of humanity's collective
knowledge every fortnight some elder
passes away and carries with them in the
grave the last syllables of ancient
tongue you know if God's all-powerful
why does he allow evil to exist in the
universe but when Krishna said to
thicken a plot you know I mean I think
cultural appropriation ranges from
stealing the Elgin marbles
you know from Greece through an ongoing
serious epidemic of marketing of the
rare treasures through illicit smuggling
you know rings which should be heavily
please don't ever leave condemned I mean
the thing that we forget is that this
incredible social transformation women
in a generation going from the kitchen
to the boardroom people of color from
the woodshed to the White House
gay people men and women from the closet
to the altar school children talking of
biodiversity the biosphere of Gaia
people beginning to abandon traditional
patriarchal religion for the for the
subtle nuances of the Dharma in Buddhism
which is one of the fastest growing
religions in the West the fact that we
really are seeing the earth in almost
metaphysical terms as as a living entity
now the all of the things from above
that I mentioned are profoundly
threatening to someone who isn't
prepared to accept them but I took
psychedelics and I'm proud to say that I
wouldn't write the way I write think
they were I think likewise I'm
have understood the nature of cultural
relativism as an anthropologist I
wouldn't treat women the way I do our
parents used to say don't take these
things you'll never come back the same
that was a whole bloody point right and
also the fact that the genies out of the
bottle ain't going back and the tsunami
of social change and transformational
spiritual growth and reinvention of our
entire sense of ourselves in the planet
it's rolling forward and you know get
out of the way if you're not prepared to
dukkha it'll drown if you're not
prepared to float upon it you know
Facebook Twitter I mean six basically
six billionaires of Silicon Valley have
within their hands the ability to
protect or frankly destroy our
democratic traditions that have
developed in such a powerful way but
always on my definition of fragile
foundation and so everybody you know who
uses cocaine has a blood of Colombian
people on their hands Wow that's going
to be a wild book yeah